two up and two down here comes matt
olsen over the last three games the
starters 19 in the third
innings without giving up an earned run
here's a swing and a pop up into shallow
right field shed long is already out
there calling for it
waiting for it to come down he makes the
catch and that'll end the inning and a
nice start for kendall graven against
his former ball club
chris bassett his second start 66
pitches in his first start
bought over the first nothing nothing
more is it first we'll do away and
that'll bring up vogelback little more
scampering to second
chapman's tag not in time first back of
the season for dylan
pretty easy steal for him runs on the
right pitch breaking ball slow curve
ball
in there easily bassett's 3-2
this is smack to the gap in right center
field daniel vogelback driving in dylan
moore
the voting train getting things going
here in the first inning what nothing
solid line drive into the gap head right
on it short swing
for bogle back gets the job done
and they count three and two so can
about engrossment on deck
is trail one nothing in the second
right field it's a long run for malik
smith he's not gonna get it
what's up the base of the wall and
cannon is going to hustle in the second
with a double
cannon goes with it perfectly to the
opposite field which is ball just kept
slicing away and mount smith
got on the ball came back to him quickly
did not handle it tried to barehand it
but mark canna thinking two all the way
and was able to make it easily
now brown taps the plate with his bat
center field lewis about two steps
toward right center
the infield they shift and just the
third baseman moore
on the left side and graveman is gonna
work from the one
by the way cannon went to third base on
the bounce out by grossman so kendall
working from the wind up with a runner
at third
and the fish to brown is on the way and
a sinker bounce back a first right to
white flipping to gravemen covering and
the inning is over
and after one and a half it's still one
nothing mariners
shed long is batting at 212 with a home
run and four runs batted in
he's a left-handed hitter
good high fastball and shed long strikes
out
third strikeout for bassette fastball
and this is one that austin allen wanted
up high it was up and
shed long and knocked out here we go top
of the third and austin allen the
catcher look
strike three call for a strikeout today
for kendall graveman
here's the sign from joe kemp's going to
take off there he goes pitts swung
on did he go they check it first base
umpire doug eddings he said he did not
hold up
a strikeout for graveman and that'll do
it in the third no runs a head noise and
one man left we go bottom three it's the
mariners here's third baseman matt
chapman
strike three called how about that for
some paint third strikeout for kendall
graveman
hudson frames it was perfect split the
corner
here's simeon he's all for two one for
11 on the series trying to break out of
it
one-nothing mariners top of the fifth
kemps it first
and from the stretch the 3-2 pitch on
the way is tapped toward third
moore has got a charging pickup throws
to first and not in time and simeon
beats it out
good hustle by marcus and a good play on
a chopper
and taking the ball in on the grass at
third was dylan moore but
simeon beat the throw kemp goes to
second
and the asf two on with you away here
comes scott
96 pitches he's got masavich warmed and
ready
now it's a shame mike can get through a
full five yep
but a nice day of work nonetheless for
kendall graveman his second start for
the mariners a second coming off to
tommy john
anthony macevic takes over on the mound
for the mariners
he's got an opportunity here to close it
down and he's got a tough hombre here
and ramon laureano misevich in his
fourth appearance at 3.00 e-r-a
in three innings of work left field
deep and that baby's gone
they're clicking now loriana with a
three-run shot
and the a's lead at three-to-one when
you're forced as a manager to bring a
left-hander face a good right-handed
hitter
this is dangerous and ramon made a pay
for it and that is a
huge blow matt chapman leads off third
baseman right hand hitter
and a 3-2 pitch swung on and popped up
third base side dylan moore looks like
he has a play he's on a warning track in
front of the day he overran it on
reaches back and makes the catch
great job to stay with it he had to look
uh up into the
roof here at the t-mobile park so chris
bassett back out there sitting at 71
pitches it's the
bottom of the sixth inning and the a's
leading in 3-1
good pitch right on the inside corner
sixth strikeout for chris bassett
lewis sees the tying run at home plate
and a 2-2 fastball right down the middle
and lewis swung through it now the ears
are going
to the bullpen for t.j mcfarland with
the left-handed batting vogelback coming
up good job by bassett he gives the a's
five and two thirds
petite is looking as efficient today as
he was last night
two quick outs now facing kyle lewis
muscled out to left center field this is
back carrying how about a 10-game hit
streak
number three on the campaign for kyle
lewis mariners within a run
106.6 exit velocity 420 feet
so here's nola says three in the
mariners two
tying run in scoring position got him
swinging with a slider and that's the
ball game
so liam hendricks gets his third save of
the year in the east for the second
night in a row defeat them the mariners
by a score of three to two